- The dominoes are already
starting to fall against Newsmax
and the defamation lawsuits
that they are facing.
Former Dominion executive Eric
Coomer has already settled
with Newsmax.
The terms of the settlement are not known,
but Newsmax had to issue a huge retraction
against the allegations that
they made against Eric Coomer,
and this is very, very
common in litigation.
Often you will give a better
deal to the defendants
who are willing to settle early
and those funds can then
be used to fund the rest
of the litigation and
get the big money items
from the remaining defendants.
So at least in the Eric Coomer
suit, Newsmax gets out early
but there are a lot of
defendants that remain.
So we'll see them in court.